i will not rest until abusers like joe
are kept as far away from animals as
possible
like you can keep me away from my
animals we will see damn right we will
joe versus carol tells the story of this
now infamous feud between joe exotic and
carol baskin it's a deep dive into
understanding who these people were you
see other sides of joe and carol it's
realistic but there's a heightened sense
of comedy and tragedy
i've had to fight for everything i got
if i stop
joe wins all of they all win we explore
how they're feud escalates to the point
of one of them wanting the other one
dead
kate has been with this project since
the beginning i listened to this podcast
on wondering i thought that's a kooky
lady she'd be fun to play and then as i
did more research i began to really
admire her what's your problem lady my
problem is i keep having to get into
fights with men like you i really want
people to see that she is a kick-ass
businesswoman a very passionate activist
and is a survivor i don't care what him
and his followers think about me he has
no idea what i've been through in my
life the writers have incorporated some
flashbacks of the lives that they had
before we meet them and i think
witnessing that will give the audience a
greater understanding of why they do
what they do
i found i had a lot more in common with
him than i expected he was gay in a
inhospitable land the more vicious parts
of joe were harder to access he reacted
to the various traumas of his life by
becoming the bully that goddamn [ __ ]
thinks i'm finished with her here she's
got another thing coming
this was an incredibly challenging show
it asked a lot of all of our actors and
john gave a performance that was
breathtaking i'm the only one who ever
loved you you don't love people you
collect them being able to balance the
moments of levity and yet get to the
moments that also will break our hearts
and kate is an extraordinarily skilled
actor who has incredible range i really
think he's evil howard i have to get him
how are you gonna do that
let's think of something together howard
and carol have kind of a soul match they
truly love care for and support each
other and building that dynamic was my
favorite part of shooting
i think eitan and his collaborators and
writers have made something very special
this series is a crazy ride it's really
compelling and incredibly emotional
these are two larger than life people
and we wanted to revel in the fun of
that and then also show you what's
underneath
you